alexej nawalny wurde gestern mit
vergiftungserscheinungen ins krankenhaus
gebracht nachdem er im flugzeug
zusammengebrochen ist der
oppositionspolitiker liegt seitdem im
koma und muss künstlich beatmet werden
außerdem sollte er nach deutschland
ausgeflogen werden da gibt es aber
heftige probleme deswegen auch die
pressekonferenz hier sehen wir gleich
die live bilder bzw wie sehen sie schon
es wird in wenigen minuten losgehen und
alle wichtigen fragen zu dem fall kann
mir jetzt viel pathos beantworten erst
bei in ihrem studio philippi ist derzeit
erstmal der gesundheitszustand von
rabbani also nach dem was wir hören ist
der gesundheitszustand nicht verändert
seit heute morgen ist es nach wie vor
ernst er ist in der intensivstation
liegt im koma wird künstlich behandelt
die offizielle spricht ist schwer aber
stabil
und jetzt geht es darum ob er auch
transportfähig ist die ärztin von
neuwahlen gesagt ja er ist
transportfähig und kann nach deutschland
ausgeflogen werden
die ärzte im krankenhaus in russland
sagen dass das nicht stimmt weil man da
immer bedenken muss dass die auch nicht
ganz unabhängig von der russischen
politik agieren und erst wenn die
russische politik das okay für die
ausreise gibt erst dann kann eine weile
auch als transportfähig erklärt werden
und nach berlin ausgeflogen werden
es ist ja von russischer seite dass er
an einer stoffwechselerkrankung leiden
soll wie viel wahrheit steckt da drin
ja also was verantwortlich ist für
diesen gesundheitlichen zustand von
allen dazu liefern die russen immer neue
erkenntnisse und die widersprechen sich
auch gerne mal
heute früh wurde bekannt dass polizisten
also ermittler und ärzte ein giftstoff
gefunden haben und eine analyse dieses
giftstoffes vornehmen wollten kurz
darauf erklärten sie nein nein man habe
gar kein giftstoff gefunden
es gebe eine andere diagnose die stehe
bereits fest und die haben an der
ehefrau von der leyen auch bereits
gesagt die ehefrau zeigte sich
fassungslos darüber und sagte mir wurde
überhaupt kann die diagnose gesagt wir
wurden einige symptome genannt aber von
einer diagnose weiß ich überhaupt nichts
jetzt kommt diese stoffwechsel
geschichte also man weiß nicht man weiß
eigentlich dass man den russischen
informationen den offiziellen
staatlichen russischen informationen nur
sehr vorsichtig trauen sollte wenn
überhaupt bislang sieht alles nach einer
vergiftung aus es ist absolut
ungewöhnlich dass ein wachsender
gesunder mann plötzlich schreiend
zusammenbricht und ins koma fällt
in russischen telegramm kanälen wird von
staatsnahen quellen das gerücht
verbreitet dass er gestern abend einfach
nur sehr viel getrunken hat aber auch
das ist natürlich völliger unsinn das
sieht alles nach einer schweren
vergiftung aus die eine weile nie jemand
zugefügt hat und wir schalten direkt
nach münster das bild 14 paul ronzheimer
paul auch du kennst dich mit dem fall
aus wir haben schon gesagt es gibt
gerade einige probleme dass er nach
deutschland kommen kann woran hapert's
zurzeit es hapert an dem was philipp
schon gesagt hat dann natürlich der
propagandaschlacht auf der einen seite
und auf der anderen seite möglicherweise
dem dass russland versucht etwas oder
der kreml versucht etwas zu vertuschen
nämlich dass er ganz offensichtlich oder
mutmaßlich vergiftet wurde
ich stehe hier in linz in der
weißrussischen hauptstadt und auch ihr
hat es spekulationen gegeben als das
ganze passiert ist ob es irgendeine art
von zusammenhang gibt man muss sagen das
sind alles spekulationen wenn man hier
mit den menschen auf der straße spricht
dann glauben sie dass nicht du wirklich
dass das eine mit dem anderen zu tun hat
aber natürlich ist es so dass durch den
fall navalny die aufmerksamkeit des
westens auf ein anderes thema gelenkt
wurde und wenn wir uns anschauen was zum
heute in mainz passiert ist da hat lukas
schinko der diktator seine spezialkräfte
getroffen und hat gesagt ich werde das
problem damit meint er die proteste hier
über die die ganze welt berichtet hat in
den vergangenen tagen dass man dieses
problem lösen werde also sieht alles
danach aus dass pluschenko gewinnen
könnte am ende ob das in irgendeiner art
und weise einen zusammenhang hat zur
vergiftung wie gesagt das sind alles
wüste spekulationen dafür gibt es keine
anhaltspunkte aber natürlich ist dieser
zeitpunkt schon erstaunlich
was gerade angesprochen das klingt alles
ein bisschen wie ein ablenkungsmanöver
um praktisch die aufmerksamkeit nach
russland jetzt zu lenken
inwiefern ist denn jetzt gehen die
menschen immer noch auf die straße in
minsk
die proteste sind weniger geworden in
den vergangenen tagen das hat damit zu
tun dass die menschen zum einen müde
sind sie sind insgesamt neun tage ihr
auf die straße gegangen zum anderen aber
auch dass die polizei und die
spezialkräfte wieder viel schärfer
reagieren wir wissen von neuen
verhaftungen die es in den vergangenen
tagen davor eben nicht gegeben hat wir
wissen davon dass insbesondere die
fabrikarbeiter unter druck gesetzt
werden dass sie den streik beenden
müssen es gibt diese rede die lukas
schenkel davor den von spezialkräften
gehalten hat das muss man sich mal
vorstellen dass in diejenigen die die
menschen in den gefängnissen gequält
gefoltert haben die am ende erst so
viele menschen hier auf die straße
getrieben haben aber lukas schenkel
zeigt sich ganz offen wenn ihnen das
zeigt auch ein bisschen dass er sich
sehr sicher fühlt dass er die das
militär also die sicherheitskräfte auf
seiner seite hat dennoch ist für dieses
wochenende ein großer streik ein großer
protest geplant morgen gibt es eine
frauen demonstration und der große tag
das ist der sonntag wo ihr erwartet wird
dass wieder zehntausende vielleicht über
100.000 auf die startelf die am
vergangen so kommen noch mal zurück auf
navalny wir haben exklusive bilder vom
krankenhaus was sind das für umstände
dort unter denen navalny jetzt mehr oder
weniger in anführungsstrichen behandelt
wird wer die genauen umstände kann ich
nicht sagen ich bin in kontakt mit
aktivisten die dieses flugzeug eben
organisiert haben aber sie sagen
natürlich dass ein krankenhaus dort
enorm ist nicht die besten
voraussetzungen hergibt um einen
patienten zu behandeln sowohl was die
ärzte also was die professionalität
angeht zum anderen aber auch die
hygienischen umstände in russland gibt
es da große unterschiede zwischen
städten moskau und sankt petersburg wo
sicherlich teilweise auch gute kliniken
gibt aber enorm sagt es mir zumindest
derjenige der in kontakt ist die gesamt
mittlerweilen dies allein ist umfeld
mittlerweile ist frau dann machen sie
sich große sorgen dass eben dieses
krankenhaus und die miserablen zustände
dort am ende dazu führen könnte dass die
situation für alexander baldi noch viel
schlimmer ronzheimer vielen dank für den
moment und wir schauen noch mal ganz
kurz auf die aktuellen bilder bisher tut
sich noch nicht so viel in der
pressekonferenz wir erwarten sie in
wenigen minuten stabschef und freund von
alexei navalny leonid volkov wird dort
über den gesundheitszustand sprechen
philipp wir haben es gerade gehört von
paul das flugzeug das steht praktisch
bereit für navalny und jetzt frage ich
mal ganz platt daher
es geht um leben und tod warum steigt
man da nicht einfach ein und fliegt los
ja das flugzeug ist seit heute früh in
omsk das steht bereit das ist
medizinisch bestens ausgerüstet das sind
experten an bord das ist alles da um
einen koma patienten sicher in die
berliner charité zu bringen dass sie ihn
nicht ausreisen lassen dass die
russischen behörden derweil nicht
ausreisen lassen hat wahrscheinlich
politische gründe die mitarbeiter von
navalny sagen man will es soweit
hinauszögern
dass der giftstoff in der wahlen des
körpers später nicht mehr nachweisbar
ist
das heißt wenn der ball die erst in zwei
drei vier tagen in einem unabhängigen
krankenhaus ankommt sprich in einem
krankenhaus das nicht unter dem einfluss
des kreml steht sondern transparent und
offen arbeiten und ermitteln und auch
kommunizieren kann dann ist die hoffnung
ist dass giftstoff ist der giftstoff
nicht mehr im körper nicht mehr
nachweisbar und dem noch wird auch viel
schwerer herauszufinden sein wer dabei
nie womöglich vergiftet hat und man muss
jetzt auch sagen die familie und die
vertrauten von dabei erhöhen massiv den
druck auf die russische regierung der
wir werden das gleich bei der
pressekonferenz erleben aber auch die
ehefrau von von der leyen hat bereits
einen brief an putin geschrieben und
gefordert lassen sie mein mann in die
bundesrepublik deutschland ausreisen
wir schauen auf die live bildern jetzt
sehen wir
es müsste jeden moment losgehen und wir
schalten dann direkt in die
pressekonferenz rein
ganz so weit ist es dann doch noch nicht
wir warten noch ein paar minuten philipp
für dich noch ein paar fragen dann von
meiner seite
du hast gerade angesprochen sie
versuchen es zu verzögern offenbar damit
das gift nicht mehr nachweisbar es dann
und wenn er an eine unabhängige klinik
käme würde das dann alles raus kommen
die charité berlin ist ja so eine klinik
richtig charité ist nicht nur eine
hervorragende klinik sondern die haben
auch große erfahrungen im umgang mit
gift opfern
die haben auch bereits oppositionelle
behandelt die mutmaßlich vom russischen
regime oder wem auch immer in russland
vergiftet wurden
zum beispiel peter wer sie live eines
der mitglieder von pride dieser dieser
band dieser aktivistengruppe der wurde
2018 vergiftet und auch in die berliner
charité gebracht
an dieser aktion war auch jaka bizilj
beteiligt der dieses flugzeug gechartert
hat jaka bizilj wird auch gleich bei der
pressekonferenz sein und und über über
den jetzigen stand dieser rettungsaktion
sprechen also die berliner charité ist
die favorisierte adresse der russischen
opposition wenn man es mit ein bisschen
zynisch sagen will also deutschland
entwickelt sich immer mehr zu einer
notfallambulanz für russische
oppositionelle
was erhofft man sich jetzt von dieser
pressekonferenz einfach die
aufmerksamkeit herzustellen oder auch
ein bisschen druck zu machen
ja man möchte druck auf die russische
regierung ausüben
allerdings ist es natürlich so man
möchte bislang sich nicht aktiv an das
ausland wenden weil man weiß der kreml
reagierte nur ungerne auf druck von
aussen der kreml lässt sich natürlich
immer wieder beeinflussen aber der kreml
will seine entscheidung selbst will ja
vielen dank für den moment und jetzt
geht die pressekonferenz dann wirklich
los wir schalten direkt rein
was eignete haben wir haben wir am 5
[Musik]
ja wir haben gestern einen unerwarteten
anrufe bekommen von anna kurnikowa von
pussy bereit und von peter wer sie los
das waren vergiftet wurde
wir waren sehr überrascht und peter wehr
sind auf dem vor zwei jahren hierzu
charity eingeflogen hat uns gefragt ob
wir mit cinema for peace so was
ähnliches eben auch für sein freund
navalny machen könnten
ich habe ich hier in meinen nachbarn
leonid volk auf den staatschef
quasi heute nacht kennen gelernt in der
internen kommunikation als der gestern
nachmittag versucht haben ein flugzeug
zu organisieren damit dieses flugzeug
mit fachpersonal mit visa mit corona
nachweis etc etc
wir waren die ganze nacht damit
eigentlich beschäftigt diese flug
möglich zu machen haben dann im letzten
moment um 23 uhr die aufnahmen
bestätigung der charité bekommen ja auch
so eine halbe stunde nach mitternacht
kam die bestätigung der russischen
behörden dass die fluggenehmigung alle
vorliegen und dann so ab 12 uhr kam die
restlichen piloten zum flugzeug und dann
um 3 11 ging es endlich los und um 311
war am destination ort schon sieben uhr
morgens
das heißt da gingen wir nahtlos über in
die kommunikation mit den leuten vor ort
und mit den medizinern und sind das
flugzeug landete heute morgen um 18
in der annahme dass dann aber mir war
nie abgeholt werden kann
aber es kann dann etwas anders als wir
erwartet hatten
ein mimi switch englischen
ein tor ist surprise achtete tolles
debüt vor dem todesort passiver leonid
chiefs of staff julia erstmal herzlichen
dank an herrn jack o'neill und silber
vor bis das war eine mögliche
kooperation und das alles möglich machen
diese spät in der nacht nach uns zu
schicken
das war ein transport ist schwierig die
situation vor ort und krankenhaus ist
dass sogar die ärzte seiner frau also
der frau von alleine keine informationen
zum gesundheitszustand nicht was auch
interessant ist was volkov krankenhaus
de facto ersetzen von männern in grauen
anzügen und damit meint er natürlich
große schöne sicherheitsmitarbeiter es
kursieren auch viele fotos davon die
unbekannte männer die sich auch nicht
identifizieren
sich im krankenhaus befinden und die
informationspolitik steuern sowie
kipsang er spricht auch unser theologie
dass es eine russische ausdruck für
diese sicherheitsleute die sich nicht zu
erkennen gegeben die die nacht im
krankenhaus übernommen haben und darüber
bestimmen was die ärzte sagen was die
ärzte tun und was die öffentlichkeit
überhaupt erfahren darf
er widerlegt auch die version der ärzte
dass es bereits eine diagnose fest
stünde und kommuniziert wurde
das stimmt nicht sagt er die ärzte haben
lediglich die symptome als erst dann so
die aber natürlich offensichtlich sind
wenn man diese auch beobachten konnte
aber von einer diagnose bislang nicht
[Musik]
das sei auch der grund warum man jetzt
unbedingt und die bundeswehr spricht
davon ist wichtig es ist dass eine
entgiftung der grund dieser vergütung
der gibt's doch so schnell wie möglich
identifiziert wird
das müsste man wissen wann denn russland
ist aus der etwas traurigen erfahrungen
zum beispiel von mitglied peter wiehle
2018 bereits errichtet wurde und zum
glück von jacada der inkonstanz daneben
sitzt nach berlins in die charité
gebracht werden kopf beschreibt dass sie
im krankenhaus eine aufklärung möglich
ist dass die ärzte verschiedene
versionen zum teil sich selbst
widersprechen der version den grundherrn
vergiftung ich getan kommunizieren eine
aufklärung einfach nicht zu erwarten ist
eigentlich nicht das den flughafen
verlassen dürften mache ich dich da
bleiben durften aber wir haben dann
lösungen von dass das flugzeug war da
geblieben so gesagt haben dass fliegt
erst zurück wenn der geplante passagier
an bord ist und dann wurde ich über den
tag und sehr viel aktivität und fall auf
allen ebenen der verschiedenen
beziehungen die man sich vorstellen kann
und irgendwann kam eine dynamik hinein
wie dann tatsächlich dann doch zu einem
fortschritt führte das aber auch sehr
viel mit dem persischen engagement der
familie und der menschen vor ort zu tun
hatte vor allem von seiner ehefrau julia
und vielleicht kannst du dazu nicht nur
ein bisschen äußern
ja denke vor dem boden
der stabschef von alleine erzählt jetzt
vom offenen marie denn die ehefrau von
alexei navalny juliana weil er kürzlich
an vladimir putin russischen präsidenten
geschrieben hat das ist ein sehr
dramatischer offener brief in dem sie
den präsidenten auffordert endlich
transport erlaubnis auszustellen das
genehmigen
der mit ihrem mann nach deutschland
gebracht werden kann soll kopf sagt dass
das sehr wichtig ist ein starkes zeichen
ist dann kocht das dass sie die
situation natürlich verändert
er beschreibt dass die ehefrau juliane
avaya eigentlich optimistisch war das
eine ausreise gestattet wird sie hat das
immer wieder beobachtet weil die ganze
nacht bei ihrem mann und als dann sie
endgültig gemerkt hat dass die ärzte
sich nicht von der stelle bewegen hat
sie sich dazu entschlossen sich und
ihrer großen reichweite sie sie ja auch
mittlerweile hat in einem offenen brief
an putin zu wenden und den kreml chef
direkt persönlich unter druck zu setzen
[Musik]
volkov sagt zum ersten mal seit vielen
stunden seien mal ein kleines bisschen
optimistisch dass es nun doch klappen
könnte mit der ausreise alexej hier ist
peter kennen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die nonsens next next few days über
computer computer vor der professor ein
halb voll charité support of messaging
wird
da war nichts
die roulette
[Musik]
jetzt teilt computer es gibt probleme
und dann versucht sich zudem zu kümmern
beta version of soll jetzt über seine
erfahrung bietet siebziger der eigenen
vergiftung die 2018 stattgefunden hat
sprechen
er war auch beteiligt dabei den
rettungsflieger zu organisieren er hat
ja caviezel den aktivisten kontaktiert
denn das flugzeug kompensiert werden
kann
kinder abzuholen wer sie los sagt das
ist bei ihm ähnlich lief wie bei navalny
auch er wurde zwei bis drei stunden
begegnet bevor er die ersten symptome
gespürt hat
[Musik]
also damals 2018 das bewusstsein fiel
ins koma wurde an ein beatmungsgerät
angeschlossen
es ist also all das was wir in den
vergangenen 24 stunden auch bei alexej
nawalny erlebt haben die ich nicht der
medizinische zustand erinnert an die
situation jetzt seiner band sondern auch
das verhalten der behörden innerhalb der
ersten 24 stunden nach der vergiftung
version of wurden ebenfalls keine
wirklichen medizinischen analysen
vorgenommen keine untersuchung keine
toxikologischen untersuchung
genauso ist das jetzt bei navalny noch
da spricht man über diagnosen die man
noch nicht hat und die man auch
niemandem weiter gibt wurde bei der sie
laufen erklärt das natürlich keinerlei
giftstoffe im körper gefunden wurde
[Musik]
die ersten tests wurden natürlich nicht
in einem russischen krankenhaus sondern
erst in der berliner charité vorgenommen
wer sie los sagt dass die russischen
behörden darauf warten dass sich der
gibt stoff aus dem körper entfernt und
erst wenn das blut sozusagen sauber
genug ist und keine spur des giftstoffes
mehr nachzuweisen ist erst dann wollen
sie gestatten dass der patient in diesem
fall alexej nawalny gegen eine andere
klinik in einem anderen land gebracht
werden kann
jetzt wird peter wer sie luft gebeten
etwas über sein verhältnis für seine
bekanntschaft zornig szenerie zu
sprechen
russland sei einer der wenigen der
effektive großen proteste organisiert
habe in russland zum ersten mal erfuhr
von der vergiftung dabei seien ihm
sofort die ähnlichkeiten die parallelen
zu seiner eigenen vergiftung eingefallen
und dann kontaktierte er jaka bizilj um
zu helfen
das entspricht gerade darüber dass die
frau von neuwahlen nicht anwesend ist
weil sie sich immer noch versucht um
organisations- dinge zu kümmern und um
zeit bei ihrem mann zu verbringen es
wurde aber auch gesagt dass sie keinen
zugang zu ihrem mann bekommen hat also
die ärzte haben wieder ihr sozusagen den
kontakten ihr mann auf der
intensivstation verboten
außerdem erzählt er dass sie immer noch
sehr sehr weit davon entfernt sind diese
situation die gerade herrscht zu lösen
also es gibt noch einige probleme
überhaupt ausfuhren nach deutschland zu
bringen und ihn in deutschland oder in
einem anderen europäischen land zu
behandeln aber dies habe bislang keinen
effekt auf wladimir putin
aber man sollte die hoffnung nicht
aufgeben und einfach weiterhin den druck
haben jetzt erstmals besucht und sie
machen gerade eine bestandsaufnahme und
wie sind wir noch guter dinge
das ist noch ein weg geben wird hannah
war die nach berlin zu fliegen
weiteres spezifische fragen können wir
gerne im persönlichen 11 interviews
besprechen
herr wolf steht ihnen zur verfügung und
wir werden natürlich dann weiter
kontinuierlich informieren über den
stand der dinge
vielen dank
[Musik]
behände zu lassen
okay wie sie aussehen also seine
aufmerksamkeit ist auf dem iphone im
permanenten kontakt mit dem
krankenzimmer mit seiner frau julia
also da geht es jetzt seit zwei tagen
tag und nacht rund um die uhr um sehr
viele wichtige entscheidung aber wir
haben trotzdem das gefühl dass es
momentan ein kleiner fortschritt gibt
und wie gesagt wir stehen gerne für
weitere fragen zur verfügung
[Musik]
soweit die pressekonferenz zum aktuellen
gesundheitszustand von alexei navalny
und auch zum stand was den transport
angeht nach deutschland findet wir haben
uns das jetzt beide angehört was ist so
deine einschätzung die beiden sind zwar
ein bisschen positiv aber es werden ja
trotzdem massiv steine in den weg gelegt
da ich glaube man muss sich einmal
vergeben vergegenwärtigen was hier
passiert da wurde ein mensch vergiftet
der liegt in schweren gesundheitlichen
zustand in einem krankenhaus das ihm
wahrscheinlich nicht adäquat behandeln
kann
und das garantiert nicht adäquat und
unabhängig ermitteln kann was mit ihm
passiert ist
und anstatt dass man diesen menschen
einfach in ein anderes krankenhaus
bringt ja dafür gibt es ja alle
ressourcen muss seine frau offene brief
an den präsidenten schreiben muss sein
staatschef in berlin pressekonferenzen
abhalten damit etwas ganz
selbstverständliches passieren kann und
das ist wirklich bewundernswert viel
kraft diese mutigen menschen haben die g
einen gesamten russischen staatsapparat
gegen sich haben und um die gesundheit
um das leben eines oppositionellen
kämpfen denn nichts anderes tut als
korruptionsskandale aufzudecken und
seine freie meinung zu sagen
vielen dank für die einschätzungen gehen
nochmal nach minsk zu paul ronzheimer
paul auch druckern dass die
pressekonferenz verfolgen ganz klare
frage wenn der ball jetzt nicht nach
deutschland ausgeflogen werden kann ist
das dann sein todesurteil
dazu kann ich nichts sagen weil ich
nicht weiß wie sein zustand tatsächlich
ist das können nur die ärzte sagen ich
glaube ein hoffnungsschimmer ist es ja
die deutschen ärzte das erste mal zu ihm
durften wie gerade bei der
pressekonferenz gesagt wurde was ich
weiß von den aktivisten das ist die
hoffnung gibt tatsächlich dass er noch
heute abend ausstiegen kann also es gibt
einen slot für heute abend der schon mal
vor gebucht würde für den fall dass sich
das ganze auflöst und es gibt einen
beitritt slot für den morgigen tag also
morgen früh
das ist sozusagen die optimistische
variante
gleichzeitig muss man sagen dass
natürlich der druck auf putin aus
russland insgesamt massiv ist ich weiß
von hintergrundgesprächen mit spitzen
politik dann das wirklich sehr sehr
viele momentan versuchen dort einfluss
zu nehmen aus deutschland aber auch aus
europäischen nachbarstaaten wir haben
von marc baum gehört die kanzlerin die
ohnehin in den vergangenen tagen häufig
mit guten gesprochen hat nämlich hier
über die lage wo ich gerade stehen muss
wird es auch versuchen also der druck
ist groß und die frage ist was ist putin
bereits zu riskieren denn je länger das
ganze dauert desto größer ist natürlich
dieser druck und möglicherweise auch die
massive kritik natürlich an ihm und dem
vorgehen dort in diesem krankenhaus
franz am besten dank für einen moment
wir haben es gerade gehört die größer
der druck wird warum warum nicht einfach
sagen gut dann flieg inhalt aus ich
meine es ist eigentlich ist es doch so
einfach
der kreml will sich natürlich keine
schwäche erlauben
der kreml gibt nicht einfach so nach
wenn man ihn unter druck setzt das hat
putin auch gar nicht nötig ja wir haben
in der vergangenheit immer wieder
gesehen dass oppositionelle vergiftet
und ermordet wurden zum teil auf offener
straße wenige hundert meter vom kreml
weg und passiert ist überhaupt gar
nichts also dieser druck der existiert
vielleicht in der öffentlichkeit in den
in den zeitungen in den herzen der
menschen
aber putin kann das völlig egal sein ja
bislang ist alles was er gemacht hat
gegen die opposition völlig ohne
konsequenzen geblieben es gibt es gibt
keine sanktionen und es gibt keinen
tatsächlichen politischen oder
wirtschaftlichen druck dass er das
einfach seine oppositionellen in ruhe
und am leben lässt deswegen putin hat
das überhaupt nicht nötig hier irgendwas
zuzulassen wahrscheinlich wird er das
irgendwann tun
ich kann mir schwer vorstellen dass es
komplett verweigert aber er muss
natürlich zeigen dass er das selbst
entscheidet und dass er nicht nachgibt
weil irgendjemand irgendwo auf der welt
sei es die ehefrau von alexei navalny
oder bundeskanzlerin merkel ihnen dazu
auffordern